[Music]
thank you all for coming on one of the
later speeches of the conference today
super excited to have you all here I'm
Mary COEs I am a product manager with
stock driver logging hi my name is
Eduardo sofa engineered a treasure data
and we're here to talk to you today
about getting started running a
centralized logging solution on Google
cloud and I have to say nothing but my
deep love of logs would convince me to
stand up on stage here so I'm really
excited to get to share with you why
centralize logs can make your life
easier how to do that in Google Cloud
Eduardo will talk a little bit about
logging and kubernetes specifically and
then some insights from managing logs of
scale that we've had we've learned
sometimes the hard way through Google so
let me see just a show of hands has any
one do we have any current Google cloud
customers in the audience who use stock
driver logging awesome and another show
of hands do we have any software
engineers from Google here who use
logging in their day-to-day life at
Google and they don't really let us into
these oh we have one yay couple so they
don't usually let us into these talks so
that's awesome the team that I work with
in Pittsburgh does both the logs to help
all of our cloud customers manage their
operations at scale but also the logs
that our Google engineers use for
understanding the applications we
develop internal to Google as well so
let's talk about why logs matter
fundamentally troubleshooting anything
but especially distributed Microcystis
services is really hard so we have in
the cloud a bunch of interconnected
pieces I like this puzzle and when
something goes wrong it's really hard to
figure out how we need to put them back
together
logs will give us visibility into our
system so in the puzzle analogy there
the picture on our puzzle pieces here
and while you could assemble things one
puzzle piece at a time a centralized log
view will allow you to see all of the
picture at the same time which will help
you to improve your reliability
performance and security so let's talk
about how we actually deliver on a
centralized logging solution running in
Google Cloud and I mentioned I am the
product manager for stock driver logging
that is one of three pillars that we
have within stock driver so we've got
logging monitoring and application
performance management or APM and each
of these are part of a SAS ops suite to
help all of you monitor and troubleshoot
your applications whether they're
running on GCP AWS or cloud native
infrastructure and trying to keep your
apps fast and available so we have a
bunch of different components here we
have log producers on the one side and
there are many different ways logs come
in that you care about so we have audit
logs which are super special we've got
platform logs that are sent from
individual Google services like cloud
load balancer we have open source
components that are creating logs that
you might be running to power your
infrastructure and your apps and then
there are logs that come directly from
the apps themselves on the other hand
we've got consumers of logs so there are
a number of different options for
consuming logs one of course is stock
driver logging some users will also want
to consume logs in a tool like Google
bigquery or save them for compliance in
Google Cloud storage or use one of the
many different partner applications that
we support including sumo logic spunk
ELQ stock just to name a few of the more
common ones so if I and the log router
is what actually glues these two things
together though the producers and the
consumers so if I look over here I've
got at the top the log producers
everything gets centralized through the
logging API and then we've got the log
router which will help us to get the
logs to the right endpoint and down at
the bottom we have the stock driver
product on the left-hand side and then
on the right-hand side we have other
potential destinations whether it's
cloud storage bigquery or anywhere else
which can go through pub/sub the in
order to get logs into stock driver
there's zero setup for GCP audit logs
and logs from GCP services so any logs
that are being created on your behalf by
a GCP service and then if you want to
instrument your code you can also use
client libraries to send logs to the API
directly but the vast majority of our
logs that aren't sent from cloud
services actually go through our open
source logging agent fluent II hello
maybe most of a you already know what is
a logging agent but a if we go like
years ago we will say that and we can
think about logging the first thing that
we can think about its maybe syslog I
have uses this look before please raise
your hand so everybody who raises the
cane is over 30 actually yeah so logging
make an sm taxes for a couple of reasons
maybe because you want to troubleshoot
you want to monitor something or
understand what's going on your
applications in your system so a what we
are talking about here login is it's not
new I think that logging exists from the
beginning since if you are doing
development you're debugging you have
some kind of login mechanism if you are
deploying your application
you have some login mechanism for that
it could be through syslog RCS law or
just write into a plain log file in the
file system but we have current problems
now in the past we used to have like a
common messages the application is doing
a b c d or it's crashing we have some
exceptions but what happens when you
have multiple applications that generate
data in a different way for example if
you know Apache web server Apache web
server creates their own lock entry
saying this is an IP address this is a
protocol version size of the document if
you look at that for example my sequel
logs they looks pretty much different
what kind of query was running a what
our reception how are the tables were a
do we have some charting or things like
that so if you want to do log in is
because not because log in is cool I
think that honestly log in is boring
from math from a play perspective so you
but you have to deal with that right
because you have problems that you need
to solve so they think is if you have
multiple source of information that come
from different places in different
formats with the optimal goal that you
want to do is data analysis so in order
to do data analysis you need a login
agent and you need to have and you this
login agent must have different
strategies to deal with data formats
data sources one thing is read log files
from the file system the audits listen
from TCP or UDP if you are using for
example hardware devices like firewalls
and they are sending their logs over UDP
you need to support that too
so when moving forward we can think
about mini logging agents but the
experience here is that treasured data
the company that I work for we created
fluently in around seven years ago to
solve the whole data collection problem
and fluency as an open source project is
fully open source under right now the CN
CF the cloud native computing foundation
the goal of this project is that allows
you to consume
from multiple places with different
formats and ingest back the information
on any kind of central database like
google stackdriver
or your own elasticsearch database or my
sequel in general as a pro ik and eco
system we have more than 700 plugins and
I think that from a company perspective
we maintain like 10 or 20 and all of the
others are made by the community do you
know foo Indy is anybody using fluent a
before here good we have some users
awesome
Thanks so once we get logs into the
centralized logging API however that
happens and many times through our
logging agent our next school is to get
it to the right destination and this is
where the log router comes into place so
we have two kind of different flows for
managing logs through the log router one
is called log syncs and that is
basically an inclusion filter so you're
going to say exactly what it is you want
sent to these destinations and if you
don't say anything nothing will go to
these destinations and we can send the
same log to bigquery and pub/sub or -
none of the above on the other side we
have logs being sent to stackdriver the
logging product yeah and we manage this
via exclusion filter so if you do
nothing all your logs will go to
stackdriver logging and then if there
are certain logs that you don't want to
go there either because you don't want
anyone in your company to have access to
them or if you don't want to pay for
them then you can use an exclusion
filter to control what goes into stock
driver logging and that's a pretty big
difference compared to many of the other
cloud platform logging experiences out
there so I'll call out two important
ideas around our log router one is that
logs can be exported to log sinks even
if they are excluded from stock driver
log storage so this is something that
can be a little bit tricky to get from
our documentation we'll work on that
but hopefully clear now
and then the other thing that's a really
powerful tool is a tool called
aggregated exports so most of our
customers have an organization with more
than one project and they want to manage
logs across their entire organization a
special use case here is security where
oftentimes the security team wants to
see the audit logs across their entire
organization and so an aggregated export
can be set up either at the folder level
or at the org and it will inherit all of
the stuff below it
so if audit logs are created for a new
project that didn't exist now in the
organization we will go ahead and
include those in the export as well
and then the last thing I'll talk about
in terms of logging tools is how you
analyze Logs with stackdriver and we'll
get to a demo here in just a moment but
stackdriver logging supports both basic
and advanced filters it we also have a
tool called error reporting as part of
the logging library toolkit here that
will automatically go through your blogs
and group like logs together
specifically looking for stock traces
and issues in your code and then we also
provide the ability to create alerts and
dashboards from logs by using a tool
called logs based metrics and that pairs
with stock driver monitoring so that's
kind of a theme that you'll hear across
the stack driver tools is that while you
can use logging by itself for monitoring
by itself or our APM tools by themselves
if you use multiple ones together you
can actually get something that is more
powerful than any of them individually
alright and now my favorite part is demo
time if we could cut over here perfect
all right so I have a web store running
on gke and I can see the logs from my
web store at a first glance I can see
hey there are quite a bit of logs looks
like a lot of errors but I'm not really
sure where to get started
there's an issue so my first stop and
first stop for many customers is let's
check out error reporting to see if it's
automatically identified anything for us
and sure enough having looked through
our logs out of all of those errors it's
identified a specific error in our
application that someone tried to set
the quantity to less than zero which
caused a specific error and I can click
on that I can see exactly how many
customers have been impacted by this
error I can see the stock trace so that
I can tell exactly where in my code this
came from and I could go to stock driver
debugging to investigate further if I
wanted to from here I can also jump
directly back to the logs to view the
raw logs I can link to an issue so this
one here looks links to a github issue
for example and I can also track the
resolution status so for example if
someone tells me one of our developers
says hey I fixed this error should be
all set it's deployed I can go ahead and
say this error should be resolved and
then we say okay no no no NER so that's
great if I go back to my catalogue here
and we'll test it to see if this
actually works and I add something to my
cart let's see what happens if we try to
set the quantity to a negative number
update the basket and I'll come back
over to error reporting and reload it
here for just a moment
this usually updates in about five to
ten seconds when we can see that it
automatically identified that the error
had been seen again and reopened to the
issue if I wanted to I could also turn
on notifications so that rather than me
going to this dashboard it'll
proactively push alerts for new or
reopened errors to my inbox so that's a
very common use case we hear from a lot
of developers who are using
driver logging but we hear a number of
other examples for like security use
cases so something that I hear a lot is
I want to be alerted if anyone adds some
an email let's say from a gmail comm
domain so I can in the UI I can interact
with it in sort of a point-and-click
mode but I can also interact with the
logs in the advanced filter and then
type in more advanced queries so in the
case of identifying something that comes
from a gmail.com account I need to
create a log space metric so that I can
then alert on that so I'm going to go
over to my logs base metrics and I've
created one here I'm gonna go ahead and
edit that metric for anything that comes
from logs that are set I am policy that
have binds a member to at gmail.com I
want to count all of these and that's
kind of the first step so I'll be able
to have dashboards about everyone who's
been added from an at gmail.com account
and then I can also create alerting
policies on that and I can see that
earlier this morning my Google account
did add somebody who was at gmail.com so
let me go back to our logs base metrics
and go ahead and show you how you would
create an alerting policy on this so I'm
going to create alert from metric this
will pop me over into stock driver
monitoring which is where I manage all
of my dashboards and my alerting
policies so I'm able to here see the
logs based metric take a look here I
haven't I don't have any recent ones but
I'm going to go ahead and create an
alerting policy if I ever see this
because that's not I don't ever expect
to see this and instead of duration I'm
going to say most recent value so if
this ever happens I want to be alerted
and go ahead and save the condition and
create a notification so
I'll send it to my favorite email
address audit logs rock at gmail.com I
can add some documentation in terms of
who to contact name this policy now go
ahead and save it so now if I go ahead
and add a new member to an IAM policy
anywhere in this project I will receive
a notification about this all right
another common use case we hear from
customers is that they want to send
their logs someplace else so this is the
beauty of the centralized logging
solution is that it all comes in
centrally and then we can slice and dice
it and send it to many different places
using exports which is the the log
router that we were talking about just a
moment ago so I'll start out with a very
common use case which is I want to send
all of my audit logs to bigquery so I
select a filter in this case I'm going
to say everything that matches the
activity audit logs in the log name and
then I simply select bigquery and the
destination and create a sink and any
future logs that match this will
automatically be sent to bigquery
which is great but that only helps me
for this project what if I want to do
this at the organization level so in
this case I need to pull up my cloud
shell here and I can use a g-cloud
command to set this at the
organizational level and I'll call out
right here we have include children and
we're setting this up at the
organization level same thing though the
log name matches the filter of anything
that has cloud audit Google API Escom
and I'm going to go ahead and save this
and now any audit logs from anywhere in
my organization will all go to the same
bigquery destination now one tricky
thing just to remember is now that I set
it up at the org level any audit logs
that come from this project will be
written twice so in that case I'd
probably want to go back
and get rid of the one at the project
level another thing that we have users
do a lot is I want to act on logs so in
this case let's say every time a new VM
is spun up I want to take a look at it
process it with cloud functions maybe
and add some labels or or apply some
roles to it so I'm going to create a
sync for any time that I have created an
instance which is the insert command and
I'll be able to send all of these to
pub/sub I can then use a cloud function
to pull all of the logs from pub/sub
process them take whatever action I want
on them so this is another common use
case we see all right and then last but
not least we'll talk about log
exclusions so we have a page dedicated
to helping you understand what your log
volume is across your various Google
cloud resources or AWS resources here as
well
and I can see for example taking a look
here a lot of my volume is coming from
this in this project is coming from
kubernetes so that's the bulk of my logs
I can see though that projected through
the end of the month is 43 gigabytes
which is well within the free limit of
50 gigabytes so I'm not too too worried
but I could go ahead and say you know
what I don't I'm gonna send these logs
maybe to my elk stack I don't want to
pay for them in stock driver I could go
ahead and disable the logs altogether
here or I could create an exclusion
filter based on this and for example say
anything that is less than a warning
level I want to maybe just sample those
logs so instead of getting excluding a
hundred percent of them maybe I will set
this to 99% I can also deep dive
into the logs volume in stock driver
monitoring using the metrics Explorer
tool and visualize exactly where my
volume of logs is coming from alright
and if we could cut back please to the
presentation awesome so now with a
solution like stackdriver we can say
that log is not long and boring but
before that handling logs in different
formats many sources and correlate data
is quite hard and I'm sure if you had
you're working already with distributed
system or cluster or with kubernetes
there's quite challenges that needs to
be solved so when going to explain now
is about hole logging operates at
kubernetes level so if you understand
the problem how it works behind the
scenes means that you can optimize the
engine queries and get better insights
from your data do we have any kubernetes
users here oh good so I'm going to do a
like a little introduction about hole
logging works in kubernetes
or when you play with docker containers
basically you have one application that
triggers a message and that message
means to be like a log a lock message
saying a status and alert a warning or
anything related for the example we have
like in X but it's not just about the
message that message has some metadata
that needs to be correlated one of them
is at what time this message was
generated and the other is what's the
channel that this nature this message
was generated from if we speak about
containers you know there there are two
main channels standard output standard
error and here for example in X is just
not in X we have a JSON example what
with metadata and that message then
needs to be stored somewhere
there are many ways to store container
logs or in kubernetes logs is for
example insistently but here we are
going to refer how docker operate
basically your message is stored in the
file system in a pad right so every
message becomes a new JSON map and every
message is appended at the end of that
file but things will become a little bit
complex later because if we think about
how Cooper needed works from an
architectural perspective we can think
about this you have your application the
most simple use case that application
it's running in a container container a
paint limitation restrictions and allows
you to set up certain policy rules and
also how this a process that is running
can communicate with others and when
they sell a container you know that
container is just a concept right from
an operating system perspective is all
about a namespaces and C groups so your
application run in a container and that
container runs in a concept which is
called a pot so things get complex
because a pot can have multiple
containers and multiple pots can be
running on the same node and a node I'm
referring to to a bare metal machine or
a beautiful machine so here is just one
single machine right but in a real
cluster you have many of them so imagine
that you have your distributed
application you tell kubernetes please
deploy my application kubernetes based
on scheduling policies it's going to
decide where these containers will run
or will scale up is we're going to
create some replicas on which note this
replicas will run unlikely not all of
them will run in the same node so these
become complex if I tell you a twenty
years ago
please look at blade locks from my
application whoa you open the terminal
you do some SSH and look what's going on
with your application just cut file and
you get the message but on this if you
have a huge cluster you cannot do in SSH
on every node
trying to find which is the darker JSON
file that belongs to the application
that I just deployed but maybe that
application will destroy it because it
failed
or it was scale it up so things become
more complex and complex because we need
to create or try to gather some context
and what do I refer with context because
your application is running in a pot
that pot has a name that pot has an ID
and identification also you are running
in a namespace if you deploy a pot that
pot belongs to a namespace it's running
in a node in a host and maybe you added
some labels and annotation to that pot
because alais may be an annotation
saying oh my this for example sorry some
labels saying that km status running or
belongs to production quality testing or
anything like that
so how do you create all these contexts
for an application which is running in
kubernetes this whole context also
happens more complexity and it's because
this because the container name and the
container a deed you can find it in the
file system and I'm talking here about
the very low-level how things operate
right you can get that but all of the
other components comes from the
kubernetes api server or the master
server so you have some information that
is locally in the node and other
information that's in a separate machine
and you need that you're loading agent
and be able to get all of this
information together and that's why the
login agent that you use and stackdriver
use needs to be able to handle all of
this for you because of course you
cannot do this manually but you need to
be the origin agent needs to be able to
query the file system understand the
messages parse the messages which are in
different formats and correlate all the
information together with context coming
from the API server and that's fluent II
actually stackdriver useful in D you
will find it as Google Flu nd because
it's a fluent deep package and ready to
use with Google services which has the
whole
extensions and integration with
stackdriver right out of the box and
once you get the things on flowing this
lock processor you can send things to a
stack driver or maybe your own database
maybe you're running on pram or you have
your own assistant to store logs so
that's why the login agents it's not
easy to be a login agent as a tool and
also needs to be able and communicate
with different components over the
network
now lock processing in kubernetes is a
it's like the next step if we think that
we have just a single node well we'll
have the master and a single node fluent
D as a login agent needs to run as a
daemon said do you know what is a demon
set is are you familiar with pot we just
poke a pot okay
a demon said it's like a pot but this
pot runs on every node of the cluster so
if you append more notes to your
kubernetes cluster like a BML meta
machine and you already deployed a demon
set you're going to get a new pot with
that demon seed running on that new node
so the way to work is a you deploy
fluent D as a daemon said of course AGG
is all already working function by
default what it does it's running and it
starts reading the whole log files that
we splaine's few slides ago and all the
content and JSON files that were created
once it read the whole content from the
application it makes sure to gather the
metadata that associate every message
with every container with every port
with labels and notations and so on so
this simple message that we started at
the beginning because becomes something
like this with context because you have
companies it has a so a host pot named
pot ad containing name namespace and so
on because then in a stack driver or any
database where you're using you know you
don't want to query a show me the
message that start with an X and you
want to say show
me all the messages that for example
that the container name so kubernetes
the container name equal next so this
metadata allows you to do a better data
analysis and help the storage solution
to create the data that you really care
about it and not query all of them
Thanks so I mentioned earlier that we
have the same team that supports both
our cloud logging solution and Google's
internal logging solution so we've
learned a lot of lessons talking to
customers who customers like yourselves
and customers at Google who use the
logging tools that we build so I wanted
to share some lessons learned one is the
value of structured logs so not all logs
are created equal they all have great
potential but if we format them in a
specific way we're able to answer
questions more easily so an unstructured
log might have a text payload of you
know blah blah blah purchased for
widgets a structured log will have a lot
of key value pairs in JSON format this
makes it much easier than to answer
questions like how many unique customers
purchased a widget how many widgets were
purchased overall if you use structured
log so you can then send when when you
for example send stuff to bigquery that
structure will persist and make it much
easier to interact with your logs
downstream as well plus you can do
things in stock driver logging like say
show me the customer ID hash I want that
to be displayed easily so I can
understand what's going on more more
quickly the other tip that we have
learned over the years is that it can be
really tricky to get the right level of
logging right if you do too much it's
crazy expensive and you can't find
anything in your logs if you do too
little then you don't have the data that
you need when you need it and so trying
to get that just right level of logs can
be a real challenge
both internal to Google and for our
customers there's no magic bullet here
but one thing we found to be really
helpful is to enforce a consistent
definition for logging levels through
your code so you know an error should be
something that really stops your code
and you expect somebody to actually
investigate here whereas maybe debug and
info are less important and that makes
it easier when I filter to quickly find
the information that that we care about
and the final kind of insight we've
derived over time is that it's really
helpful to have data about the log
volume so that you can iterate and
refine this over time so specifically in
stock driver logging we have metrics at
a very fine grain level so you can see
not only which resources are sending
logs but which logs or which you know is
that are you getting mostly errors or
these mostly info statements and you can
slice your and dice your data in all
sorts of ways which can allow you to
iterate on your logging solution over
time thank you
so getting back to logging agents and
there are many solutions and open source
breaks available but a when talking
about specifically about foolin D which
is the fault aging stack driver and also
for open C from Revit and other
companies and products a we can think
that flew Indy is more than just a
simple open source project I would like
to say that it's a full ecosystem since
the moment there are many companies
contributing back to the same project
means that is small revelant for
relevant for the market and also it's
becoming a huge solution and at some
point people said that flew Indy for
some cases was too heavy or we have some
performance issues and sometimes the
answer is not the answer but the back
question is how many records are doing
just in per second sometimes they say a
few thousands per second
of course you're going to have some
performance penalties you need memory
CPU and you are filtering data and you
have like 10 filters that is time
consuming and they said ok but we need
something lightweight flowing the
original is reading in Ruby and C is
quite performin but at high school some
companies and user customers said we
need something that can be lightweight
and more tied to cloud native solutions
and that's why we created a second
project which is called full embed
created same by treasurer data now
driven by the community it's also in the
with a cloud native compute foundation
and flue embed try to solve the problems
in the cloud native space in a different
way using the same background or
experience from flue in D this is not
like a replacement for flu in D but most
of cases people said I want to use flu
in D and for this special namespace
cluster I'm going to run flu and bit
because of performance reason or special
features and the good thing about flu
embed is that it's reading in pure and
CC language it's optimized for
performance low memory footprint and it
also has a pluggable architecture it's
pretty much a flu Indy but flu in the
ecosystem is quite huge we have 700
plugins here we have like 45 so you can
see that it's more time for specific
things and it's fully integrated with
coronaries and permit use and it's a sub
break of the CN CF and a like a kind of
announcement we are releasing in a
couple of days the new version which is
called youth at 14 I think that
sometimes numbers does not been
something the pre has been around for
more than three years so but we try to
have the one that all at the end of the
year and what 0.14 will have integration
with Google stackdriver
it will not a at the beginning square
this implement integration is quite
experimental means that it doesn't have
the whole futures that Google Flu in the
house but we are working on that also we
will have the load balancing
capabilities in logging this one is best
a future that if you are dispatching
your logs to your service and you have
some neighbored outage your login agent
needs to be able to recover from that
situation meaning doing buffering or
maven trying if it's faithful point a
try to do some balancing and try point B
or a different note so that balancing
capability is coming up right now and
also we're happy to say that we are
implementing a new way to do filtering
in a login agent if we wanted to do some
filtering of flu in D you had to write
your own Ruby script for filtering but
if you wanted to do it on full in bed
like few weeks ago you had to write your
C filter and for some people said I
cannot write C is too complex and I
don't have the time which is right and
when we're we were in Europe at the
beginning of this year in Q Khan and
some people say a GD P R is coming and I
was not aware about gdpr okay what is
gdpr to me explain it to me more about
it and they said okay we need to office
K data we need to add some conditionals
for the configuration for flu in bed and
the exact ABCD okay that is too complex
we cannot maintain many multiple plugins
for different needs
yeah because they said our logs are
credit-card transactions and they have
the whole numbers and we need to office
KT there so we need a solution right
that is important so we said okay a new
way to do filtering will be let's try to
do some scripting you run fluent bit as
an agent but also when it starts you can
start your own scripts
reading in Lua language which are quite
performant and you can do all the data
modifications that you want with a low
performance penalty and also we have an
address here if you want to get more
about all the news on full and busier
that 14 to be released there's a link
and the slides tell you what you can
reform what you can sign up to get the
news and we're taking the the Lua script
this is like a simple plugin
well this is a like a text file this is
Lua with basically you create a new
using Lua tables where you can put the
old content in in one index tree and
their new content in a new key and just
return those values and flow and bid
will be able to understand that this
modification were requested from Lua and
will modify your records for you so you
don't need to create a new filter for
Fulham bead and just write your own Lua
scripts so flim it is a quite exciting
project and actually we get like from a
docker and kubernetes perspective we get
like $50,000 away and growing which is a
lot so we expect to reach a huge
millions at the end of the year thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]